Milano for him at hamdulillahi rabbil
alameen wa sallahu wa salam o allah
rasool e kareem i'm a bad law subhanahu
wa'ta'ala has instructed us in numerous
places in the quran he has said subhana
wa ta'ala well - between you and alikum
do not invalidate your deeds he said
elsewhere in the Quran yeah you had
ladina aminal lair - between Losada
catacomb he has said that which
translates to o you who have believed do
not invalidate your charities now this
is an interesting concept because islam
not only teaches us how to gain but it
also teaches us how to keep and guard
our gains and so this series how to gain
what you keep meaning those things that
really matter in life the things that
will carry on through the stages of
death those things that will carry on to
meeting your Lord
Suppan Ahuja to Allah those things that
will be with you on the day of judgment
your actions your deeds so we are going
to discuss in this series how to gain
what you keep but not just that but also
how to keep what you gain because it's
not just about giving the eggs into the
baskets but it's how to make sure that
you keep them in the basket and that you
don't shoot yourself in the foot the
Prophet sallallahu wasallam has
mentioned this concept in Sahih Muslim
[Arabic recitation]
that the prophet sallallahu alayhi wa
sallam i said i said 1 ml Mullis do you
know what a bankrupt individual is they
said that a bankrupt individual that we
know is that is an individual who has no
wealth has no property the Prophet
sallallahu aceldama said the bankrupt
individual from
nation meaning on the day of
resurrection the truly bankrupt is one
who will come on the day of resurrection
having amassed for himself abundant
reward from prayer from fasting from
charity but this person will also have
amassed a great amount of sin he will
have insulted people he will have
transgressed to people he will have
overstepped his bounds oppressed others
wrong to others the prophet sallallaahu
aceldama said that this individual his
good deeds that he had amassed for
himself will start to be distributed
amongst his victims each victim will be
given of this individual's good deeds
and if his good deeds run out before
retribution has had before those wrongs
are righted then his victim sins will be
placed on him and he then in the
Hellfire may Allah protect us and so in
this series we're going to discuss not
just how to gain and how we are sure
that something is acceptable with Allah
[Arabic recitation]
Alem sallallahu wasallam ala nabina